hope you didn't have plans to go to the
bieber concert man no i didn't however
lots of people did and they're very
disappointed uh justin was forced to
postpone his two hometown shows in
toronto as uh for doctor's orders
sharing the news on his insta stories
just before the seven o'clock concert
last night justin wrote this can't
believe i'm saying this i've done
everything to get better but my sickness
is getting worse my heart breaks that i
will have to postpone these next few
shows doctor's orders to all the uh my
people i love you so much and i'm gonna
rest and get better yeah justin was
scheduled to perform at toronto
scotiabank arena for back-to-back shows
on june 7th and 8th and he also canceled
his next stop in washington dc on june
10. his justice tour twitter account
announced details are still to come
regarding rescheduled dates and refunds
and no other details have been revealed
pertaining to his sickness this is like
the third postpone yeah
this was this is postponed from a
different album even yeah right from
time to twenty yeah yeah to now yeah uh
i know a lot this reminds me of uh when
everybody flew to vegas to see adele
um because those fans are now getting
because remember she canceled the night
before her residency was supposed to
start and everybody you have to travel
to vegas right
and the and her explanation at the time
was we're going to work just to get this
done and there's been radio silence
there's been they've received no
information on uh when those shows are
going to be uh rescheduled it's the same
thing with these bieber fans it's like
how many times can you ask people to
just pack up because because this was
the toronto show there were people who
flew here from ireland from all over the
world from germany because they wanted
to see bieber in his hometown because
that would have been cool like this was
a special set of circumstances for these
shows
it's not it's not great all around like
obviously um he's ill and if he's
feeling awful you know he's not going to
do a good show so you came all this way
to see not the best version of the guy
that you love and also his fans really
do want him to get better that's true
but you can't like ignore the fact that
it's such a bummer for people that
traveled i read one tweet about this
woman who was on just the train
with these bieber fans with this mom and
daughters that were ready to go and
someone on the train told them it was
cancelled no
and they just broke
right
it's not good yeah no it's it's i mean
it happens and did they say whether this
was coveted or not because that's
immediately what everybody thinks right
yeah i
there have been no details given
regarding what it is because they were
in his last sort of run was um new york
that's when they got
they said it was nice
um the the last run of shows he did was
in new york and that's when he and haley
got turned away at that uh fancy italian
restaurant and had to go and had to go
somewhere else um and then i think that
he was in michigan the the other night
on on sunday night but no it sucks for
fans and you know this is the third time
these shows have been postponed and i
think that that is just a lot to ask it
is tough that being said there are
there are enough people that maybe
didn't get a ticket to this one
or would be patient enough that when he
came back they'd jump on it but would
these shows not be entirely populated
mostly by people who already had tickets
to the previous shows if they're just
postponements and not kids so are you
saying that if they
but if they
honor those people's tickets
for the next show they'll come back
but what i'm saying is these people who
had tickets last night were from 2020
were probably from yes because they
weren't canceled they were postponements
because this is why they postponed
because if you cancel you have to refund
here's a funny thing right so you
postpone so you don't have to refund
yeah but if you're
if you were
like nine
yes when it was when you were excited to
see bieber the first time and now you're
i'll let the next time you're gonna be a
teenager yes
by the time it comes back down yes
that's crazy yeah it is